what do you need to be good at cs go
is it god-like aim a massive brain
unparalleled game sense the real answer
is nerves of steel so now it comes down
to a 2v3
but look at this move from shocks he's
just sitting underneath this guy
working his way in so slowly oh that
patience pays off he can line up
oh my goodness he could even lie maybe a
two for one if they do it
[Laughter]
i couldn't take it either i could not
take that today we wanted to celebrate
the most patient
disciplined and downright incredible
plays in cs go history
but before we get to that i want to tell
you that this video is brought to you by
razer
and their brand new razer black shark v2
headset
if you want to hear your opponent's
footsteps in the highest quality
possible you got to get yourself a pair
of these
they have crisp and clear audio a
cardioid microphone a usb sound card for
incredible sound isolation
and they're pretty comfy too alright now
that you know all that
here are the top 10 trigger discipline
plays in cs go history
kicking off our list is sunny with a
play that truly
exemplifies trigger discipline sunny's
big bulbous brain bulging
out of the back of ivy to close this
second map up against existence during
cs summit 6 europe
sunny found a pretty easy shot onto
hectares but
instead of just taking the kill he
decided to follow him
and see if he could lead him back to his
teammate sunny
oh toss oh no he's just gonna walk right
by
oh sonny my man he's gonna sit on this
one
he's gonna back up with him assuming the
other t is also not looking now he's got
the information
sonny he's just got to shoot them both
in the back of the head and just like
that
sonny positioned himself perfectly
turning an easy kill into a sneaky beaky
1v2 clutch
taking the number nine spot on our list
is stanislaw who lays down the law
against astralis an absolutely
world-class play coming out here
how do you have the nerve to do that
it's hard to be super sneaky when you're
going up against astralis
they're such an organized team that they
leave no gaps in their defenses to slip
around
but somehow at the berlin major
stanislaus snuck into a corner and
caught astralis by surprise
tarik has rotated away from ramp which
again is going to give a nice avenue to
that lower bomb site there is
one player here oh and he goes forward
with the famas as well he's letting them
come he is such a crazy player stan i
can't believe he just did that he gets a
triple as well
an absolutely world-class play coming
out here how
do you have the nerve to do that
res takes a number 8 spot on our list by
stopping a 16-0
right in its tracks nothing hurts more
than a 16-0 loss
so managing to stave one off is a truly
heroic feat
especially when you hold your fire for
just the right
moment astralis in prime position gonna
have to try and hold the line all by his
lonesome
and the sentinel has been the best here
forest in the mall gonna get flashbang
able to at least take glaive with him
but rez he's playing this one so slowly
he is waiting for as many terrorists to
push past him as possible but in doing
so he's baiting the rest of his
teammates can he feasibly stop this from
getting done
oh he's picked up two looking for a
third lancet onto the bench as well
can't get the force as mages does but
there's boris
i thought reza made it too hard but he
pulls it back
[Applause]
taking the number seven spot is the
clutch minister himself
zip nicks absolute perfection once again
from zipmax he's the mana close it out
having good trigger discipline under
pressure can be extremely
difficult but imagine keeping your
trigger finger cool in the final map of
a major
grand final zypix could just be patient
now let noise reveal all oh he's gonna
be spotted though circa didn't see it
he didn't realize his own gun i think
blocked the vision and now zypix knows
that they're working in
one above oh he's the lamb and that's
the slaughter because it's difficult
somehow zip nicks held back waiting for
the perfect moment to pull the trigger
and send ants to the slaughterhouse
on this list you're either astralis or
you're beating astralis
which is why apex is taking the number
six spot for his beautiful dissection of
the danish squad
you'd love to see it i think i heard the
pretty loud
from from the the main room where the
players are in astrologers didn't check
behind them as they pushed up onto
monster which meant that apex could let
four players pass by before unleashing
swift and brutal death on the best cs go
team
of all time apex b in this situation is
he just gonna
whale out on the first person he sees
don't fire on first shot
don't fire a first shot this is perfect
apex that's him all past four
players now how many will he possibly
get he's gonna wait for them to line up
they're all grouping he's told kenny and
now he's gonna execute them all four
kills for apex
perfect lineup very well played
taking our number five spot is golden
with a play that makes tylu
look like jokers what's you're gonna be
going through
waiting for him will be captain mo and
takes his head off as well
leaving it down to golden to do all of
the work they've come straight past him
there's three he'll spray down all of
them
a magnificent play from golden to save
them in this round
gets the fourth as well is there one
more for the books yes there is another
ace
comes in the second and for a different
fanatic player as well
sandwiched in the cranny on banana
golden let three members of tai lu pass
before popping out to blast them
then he turned around and tagged their
teammates too trigger discipline can win
around
but if you're a truly patient god of cs
it can get you the ace too
taking the number four spot is kerrigan
with a disciplined
big brain play up against windigo during
dreamhack open tours 2019
kerrigan hatched the perfect plan by
rotating around the entire map
he caught blocker by surprise but what
happened next
was true genius one bullet away from
death is he really about to fully
bamboozle windigo
he's going up onto a through b
gonna catch this player in the back with
a deagle we saw a nightmare yesterday
he got cs god fully there's nothing
wrong about that
between the shoulder blades victor
doesn't have a kit
if he holds down on this he's going to
have to wait for 10 seconds carrigan's
not buying it
he is holding position he is taking all
the risks
and he will get the reward what a play
from carrick
like a snake in the grass kerrigan
waited for the perfect moment to strike
and didn't move an inch until he had his
prey dead
to rights sometimes
you just need to flex on him which is
why our number three spot is going to
this
absolutely filthy play from fur
what decision making from fur with a
that is glorious playing against nrg
during ecs season one
luminosity were stuck on an eco they had
nothing to lose and
even just one kill would help them in
the rounds to come but fur
wanted more and oh first position is
somewhat fantastic how has he
mr boom bastic one might say
is he gonna go the thing is you can't
really go for a knife because it takes
longer
to be ready oh james this is so good
what is this oh my god three two oh
my god oh my god that's ridiculous
and he's got the bomb and the lego gets
shot in the face what decision-making
from fur
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
a play from snacks that put
nip down for good you just have to
wonder
when was he going to pull the trigger
and when he did
it was quite magnificent at esl one
cutoff 2014
snacks and avertis pro managed to take
the lead against the seemingly
unbeatable ninjas and pajamas but snacks
had to make sure nip didn't make a
comeback so he slipped behind enemy
lines and
sealed their fate mowed down by a
bulldozer that is neo
and garlic oh you would have bet your
house on him hitting that frag forrest
picks him off it
he is down in the end by taz they're a
man to the good here vertice bro
but uh that is massive
but snacks is walking around and just
walking in a snack toward the land
he gets a double trigger he waited he
waited he waited
and then he finished off the job you
just had to wonder
when was he going to pull the trigger
and finally taking our top spot is the
single most
disciplined play in cs history a place
so iconic and incredible that it
literally named the part of the map
it happened on the patience the patience
is so good he waited for the perfect
opportunity
moment and he comes up with that and we
are going to ot
on the third map at the sivo season 5
lan finals shroud had his back
against the wall if cloud9 lost one
round
they lost a tournament winning would
force overtime and give c9 a fighting
chance
they tried to force by to stay alive
which meant that all that shroud he had
was a cz
to challenge eye by power he thinks he's
in a spot that they don't know about so
he's sticking there hoping that they
push through this book
but they're alternating i know they're
coming back i buy power cannot afford to
make the same mistake they made earlier
in the game
25 seconds left if the clock runs out on
them and they give up over time
it will be the heartbreak of a
generation
molotov's in set piece out shroud has
let them all pass
one two three oh jesus
oh my god
oh my god huge play by shroud right
there
from high above his enemies shroud
rained down sweet
sweet justice ripping i buy power apart
since then everyone just calls that spot
on cash as a site shroud
alright folks that's our list if you
think we missed anything let us know in
the comments below and while you're down
there why don't you like the video and
subscribe to the channel and if you've
got some time on your hands
head over to twitch.tv s4 esports and
throw us a follow over there so you
never
miss a stream thanks so much for
watching and we'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our
instagram twitter and facebook pages